est à madame Isabelle le calenec merci
monsieur le Président dans la loi
travail il n'y a pas que l'article 2 il
y a aussi le 21 qui sanctuarise le
compte pénibilité dans le compte
personnel d'activité ce compte
pénibilité cristalise le mécontentement
c'est peu de le dire en particulier dans
l'agriculture l'industrie le BTP il va
alourdir dangereusement les charges qui
pèsent déjà sur toutes les entreprises
mais en plus d'être une bond à
retardement sur le plan financier il est
un véritable casse-tête à mettre en
œuvre
260 pages de texte d'application au 1er
juillet soit dans 2 jours chaque
entreprise va devoir s'équiper écoutez
bien d'un chronomètre pour mesurer le
temps écoulé entre les différents gestes
répétitifs d'un rapporteur pour mesurer
la position des membres supérieurs d'une
balance pour évaluer les charges
soulevées
ou tracter d'un logiciel pour faire
évaluer les risques chimiques par des
laboratoires indépendants et craqués il
faudra en conséquence se poster derrière
chaque salarié pour procéder par cycle
et au cours d'une journée à
l'observation des tâches et à
l'évaluation individuelle des facteurs
d'exposition recourir à un laboratoire
indépendant pour mesurer les vibrations
au poste de travail dégager du temps
pour recenser les évaluations et
calculer les cotisations pour les
organismes sociaux à la place des
organismes sociaux sans compter que ce
dispositif risque de générer
d'inévitables contentieux peu propice à
l'amélioration du dialogue social dans
les entreprises alors en revanche
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
est un objectif partagé mais ce C3P
s'apprête à littéralement plomber la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
et vous savez très bien monsieur le
Premier ministre avez-vous enfin y
renoncé et à défaut il faudra cesser de
dire que vous aimez les entrepris parle
est à Madame myiam elcomery ministre du
Travail de l'Emploi de la Formation
Professionnelle et du dialogue social
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Députée locale onc il y a en effet deux
visions deux projets de société
différents et d'ailleurs la loi travail
telle qu'elle est sortie du Sénat en
supprimant au-delà du compte engagement
citoyen le compte prévention pénibilité
et à la hauteur de ce que vous venez
d'indiquer à l'instant la pénibilité
c'est quoi c'est une espérance de vie
qui est beaucoup moins longue pour une
certaine partie des salariés c'est ça la
réalité de la pénabilité vous en parler
tout le temps nous avons mis en dans le
cadre de la réformme s'il vous plaîtt
nous avons mis s'il vous plaît nous
avons mis dans le cadre de la réforme
des retraites quatre facteurs de
pénibilité ont été mis en œuvre 26000
entreprises 500000 personnes ont pu
bénéficier de points de pébilité ils
servent à quoi ces points benah
justement à plus de justice sociale
c'est-à-dire que les personnes qui ont
été dans les travaux pénibles puissent
partir plutôt à la retraite ou alors
accéder à un premier niveau de
qualification et changer de métier c'est
pas ça non plus le modèle social
deuxième chose il y a six facteurs
quelle étit la demande des organisations
patronnales c'est justement que c'était
trop compliqué qu'il fait alléger les
charges pour les entreprises qu'est-ce
que nous avons fait nous avons supprimé
la fiche individuelle justement pour
faciliter le travail des chefs
d'entreprise mais cela à une condition
que les branches professionnelles
mettent en œuvre des référentiels de
branches pour faciliter les entreprises
et qu'est-ce que nous constatons et
d'ailleurs le ministère de la Santé le
ministère du travail ont toujours dit
qu'ils étaient à la totale disposition
de chacune des branches professionnelles
certaines l'ont fait dans les boissons
il y a un référentiel homologué par le
ministère du Travail et d'autres
actuellement nous ne savons pas c'est de
la rétention ou c'est de la complexité
et nous sommes prêts justement à aider
les entreprises parce que nous savons
bien que s'il y a pas de référentiel de
branche cela sera beaucoup plus
compliqué bien sûr aujourd'hui pour les
chefs d'entreprise qui devront le mettre
en œuvre enfin permettez-moi de vous
dire que moi je condamne les propos de
Pierre gataz justement quand il appelle
quand il appelle à ne pas respecter la
loi ce n'est pas possible dans un état
de droit qu'on appelle à ne pas
respecter la
loiité la parole est à